this is a little piece of jazz history
and it's one of the coolest things I've
ever held it's three cropped photos held
together with scotch tape and a note
dictating how to print the negatives for
the final photos the remarkable thing
about this post-it note size image is
how little it changed when it became the
full album cover for jazz saxophonist
Joe Henderson's 1966 classic mode for
Joe the story of how this became this
didn't start in 1966 it started in 1939
when two Jewish German immigrants
Francis Wolff and Alfred Lyon started
the Blue Note jazz label in New York
City that would come to be revered not
only for its sound but for its iconic
album covers
what they were going for was they wanted
to make Tunes that were memorable that
people could walk out of a club humming
and that had a certain amount of soul to
them that's Michael kikuna a record
producer and Blue Note aficionado that
soul sound Michael's describing was
called hard bop genre of jazz steeped in
gospel and rhythm and blues that became
synonymous with Blue Note by the mid
1950s the mastermind behind the sound
was recording engineer Rudy Van Gelder
when you heard a Blue Note record you
heard a lot of air coming through the
saxophones and the trumpet and you heard
all the power and crystal details of the
drums that description is fully evident
in Art Blakey and the Jazz Messengers
the drum Thunder sweet
[Music]
[Music]
that was kind of the classic time for
modern jazz and New York was heaven on
earth there was a record store on every
other block swept all up not midtown but
also the village in Harlem and if you
went to those record stores it probably
wasn't the sound of Blue Note that
immediately caught your attention it was
their album covers their bold use of
color intimate photography and
meticulously placed typography came to
define the look of jazz during the 1950s
and 60s these covers are energetic moody
and they're sophisticated these album
covers are jazz now if you flip a blue
note record over it's likely you'll see
two names credited for its look cover
photo Frances wolf cover design read
Myles Francis will started shooting
every blue note session the minute he
arrived one of the most impressive and
kind of shocking things was that the
average success rate of those photos was
really extraordinary
he's like the jazz artist of photography
in the sense they could nail it
immediately but the person who decided
that this photo would be this cover was
graphic designer
Reed Myles he could look at a contact
sheet zero in on one image the URI might
not even think twice about and find a
little crop of a square that would be
like wow that's a dynamite image
yeah that is dynamite one of the things
that amazed me was what I call the
pullback effect take Hank Mobley's no
room for squares there was a new subway
station that was built it was unlike any
other subway stop it had these metal
concentric circles now try to find the
final album cover there it is the
pullback shows you the whole image and
it gives you an insight into the eye of
the designer that I think is absolutely
amazing
this is Lee Morgan's search for the new
land what was really going on was Lee
was listening to the music and sitting
next to him was Alfred Lyon with his
eyes closed in a reverie listening to
the same music
[Music]
by the 1960s Reed became more and more
adventurous and how he'd use typography
sometimes omitting photos altogether
this is Joe Henderson's 1964 album in
and out a tiny crop of a photo of
Henderson plays a supporting role
through a bold and energetic design with
those arrows driving the feeling of the
album's title home there's a jack in the
cleaned-up called it's time there's that
tiny crop of a photo again and then just
exclamation points for the rest of this
covered black type on white and it's
just startlingly beautiful and
startlingly getting your attention but
some of my favorite blue note covers are
the ones where Reed uses wolfs
photography as a playground for
typography if you look at the contact
sheet of one of us the upper right hand
shot is the one that Rin Myles focused
on that would probably be one of the
least memorable images on the contact
sheet there's photos of Herbie Hancock
and Joe Henderson and also there's two
shots Tony Williams who in this photo
looks 17 years old and who is 17 years
old but we chose this image and
perfectly placed the title of the album
right in Kenny Durham's hand he did this
with Freddie Roach as good move and fit
our man in Paris around Dexter Gordon
cigarette what always amazed me about
part directors was the ones that could
create a look for a record that was
highly individual but also that fit into
a stream that gave the label a look
we'd miles was a master
[Music]
you